it.
Right. Like otherwise it doesn't mean anything.
Right. Like ratings don't mean it. It's appealing.
Well, what does that mean? Like, so I, that's
how my brain works is I like to kind of start
high level and then get into the weeds. And
I, that's why I was interested in doing this
because I like when things summer at can
give me a summary based off of like what,
what they're seeing. That's you know that
like it's interesting to me because it's
like, okay, you take my data and then you're
like, this is what we think that you are
wanting to know . And I was like, oh no,
like it didn't really check the box because
it thought of like the screeners as a bigger
deal.
You know what I mean? So I was like, okay,
that didn't check the box. But I do like
the idea of something bubbling up and saying
here's a quick high level overview if that
makes sense. And sorry, that was.
I love all this clarification that you're
giving me.
I love it.
And there are two points. One point that
you mentioned about not quite checking the
box. I want to actually come back to it when
we are really interacting with the feature.
So Jacqueline, so you as someone who does
both quantitative and qualitative surveys,
it seems to me in general the data analysis
process for you looks like.
So there are specific survey questions that
answers your particular research questions
and your general process process is looking
at maybe those specific questions to get
like over a picture for a quick update and
then looking at the open ended question just
to understand the why behind those ratings.
Yeah, that's my first.
And I'm also just curious about is there
anyone else involved when you're doing the
data analysis in your surveys?
Sometimes I'm a pretty small, you know, I
have some people that I work with. If anybody
is doing it with me, it's typically the clients
because we're on a quick turnaround.
So I, I, let's see. I don't trust people.
Like, I, I found that I have a hard time
try because I've seen so much bad data. Right.
Like you've seen it.
I mean, I mean, there's nothing I can do
about it.
Right. Like, Right. Like people are just.
And I think that if it has my name on it
and it's going through my company, I have
to look through it.
Right. So even if I just do that step and
then I have people go through and, you know,
enter the data into the, the, the recap,
which I again normally do, if not my client
will do that and have someone on their team
do it versus because that part is daunting.
Right. Like we have to take all the data
and then enter and it's that to me, seems
like something should be able to do this
for us. Right.
Like, I know that Qualtrics has, does a pretty
good job with. They have a dashboard that
you, it just takes a long time to then build
the dashboard. You can say like, oh, I want
this and I want the top box and then the
top two box combine and like you can give
all these rules and it does it. Okay. There's
no, I have not figured out how to just dump
it right in.
Right. Versus manually entering all the data
into the, into the recap decks.
That makes a lot of sense. And speaking of
data analysis, I'm actually curious about
your experience with using AI. Like, how
has AI played some role in your survey workflows,
if at all?
Yeah. So it's funny, I was actually just
talking about this with my family the other
day. So I have a, we do a big call every
couple months with one of my bigger clients
and it's very, very quick Turnaround. Walk
like 150 people through a lab store. We get
their feedback and we have to report to the
executive team like two days later.
And the one slide that is like really daunting.
It's a ton of data. You put the numbers in
and then you have to rank it and then you
have to analyze it compared to last year,
like it's, it takes me usually a couple hours,
truly, because I have to then think it through
and cross check like all of these things.
And I must have hit something that I didn't
mean to on copilot on PowerPoint, because
I copy and pasted the template which had
it filled out from the one before, and I
may have accidentally hit Copilot or something.
But it automatically generated the whole
slide. It, it's, it would have was accurate
because I double checked everything and it
was way more detailed than I would ever write.
Mostly like client facing. But it gave me
so much information and it did the statistics
for the data down to like comparing it to
last year and I, I don't know how it did
it or what I did and I was in such a hurry
I didn't have time. I was just like, thanks
Jesus.
Like that was like it was just a gift right
from AI. And that I think was the first time
I've used AI for data. I use AI for open
end, like qualitative quite a bit. It's hard
not to. I originally was like, you know,
a real human needs to read all of this stuff
and I think you do.
But I mean AI writes better than I do, you
know, and then it will learn like my style.
So I have been using AI now to fill in my
qualita- like my open ends and then I'll
go back and I will still read through everything
usually. But I mean, I mean it has changed
the way that I'm writing my reports and they
look better, you know what I mean? Like they're,
they're better and yeah, yeah, makes perfect
sense.
This is such a nice segue to the actual feature,
the AI summary. As I said, this is meant
to give you summary of the selected key insights
and trends.
Jacqueline, before the session, have you
tried out the feature yet?
Yes, I tried it. I think I started it last
whatever day we scheduled it and then I had
time yesterday to go through it.
Perfect. And it would be really great if
you can.
I actually want to check in if you feel comfortable
to log into your SurveyMonkey platform and
choose the survey on which you use the feature.
And also do you feel comfortable to screen
share a perfect. Thank you. Yeah, amazing.
And I am actually going to take my screen
to my right side of monitors.
Okay. I can see things better. Okay, Jacqueline,
tell me a little bit more about this survey
where you use the feature.
Okay. So I use it on this Red Life Red Light
Therapy survey.
So this survey here I'm going to walk through,
you know, because I got your invite saying
to use it and I was like great. I didn't.
Most of the surveys that I have on my private,
on my personal account I don't necessarily
use for insights. Right. Like I use for,
for screening for recruiting. So but this
particular one, this Red Light Therapy survey,
I, I was, I did need to pull the data yesterday
so I felt like Two things. Oh, I'm clicking
on it.
Nothing is happening.
Hold on.
Okay. So I went and generated.
Of course it's going super slow. Let me close
some of this out.
Oh, thank you.
Okay. Okay.
Oh, no, I can't. Okay, so I know it's just
a test, but I. The biggest. Initially, the
biggest hurdle was I basically hit generate
the summary on the AI Summary, which I think
is on this page. I don't know why.
My Internet. So, yeah, generate summary.
And then it said it's going to take a few
minutes. So I ended up like going back to.
I'm gonna take my.
My video off, so maybe it will go a little
faster. So I ended up.
Doing some other things because I didn't
really need it until later on anyway. And
I ended up back on the homepage and I was
looking for it and I couldn't find it. And
I was like. I felt like it should be like,
this is the home page, right. For SurveyMonkey.
And I felt like it should be somewhere where
it would be like my summaries. You know what
I mean? So then I had to go back and it actually
happened twice. It wasn't like.
Anyway, making it just like on the homepage.
I felt like it should be easier to find interesting
because then I went back here.
And then it says, we'll save it to the dashboards
page. And I didn't. Honestly, I was like,
I don't even know what the dashboards page
is. I guess it would be this, right? Exactly.
Exactly.
Oh, yeah. I wouldn't have known that. I don't
know. I never used that page.
I. So that just wasn't. And it just wasn't
intuitive to me to go there. So that's.
Thank you.
I hope. Okay.
So then when I was like, oh, yeah, like,
I just thought that would be. Dashboards
would make sense for me to have access on
the home page. Right. Where I can just quickly
get to some of the. My.
My findings without having to, like, dig
through.
Makes sense. That is really great insight.
Something I haven't really thought about.
So thank you so much for sharing that. I
appreciate it.
Okay, so we are here. Yep. And Jacqueline
pretended I'm your colleague. That my first
time seeing this report. Could you actually
just walk me through this report, like, section
by section?
Just briefly?
Yes. So you want me to walk you through it
as if I'm downloading you or. Oh, exactly.
As I am.
As you're updating me. Like downloading me.
Summary to each section, please.
Great. So we conducted this quick survey
to get Feedback on red light therapy in Columbus,
Ohio.
And really the overall findings here are.
Well, the objective was exactly that. Kind
of understand the consumer perception and
red light therapy and what would motivate
them in terms of the benefits. And then really
kind of reading through these high level
responses, you know, the things that pop
the most as we kind of expected as we heard
from the client, were reducing fine lines
and wrinkles, improving skin elasticity and
also reducing stress and anxiety. In that
one was exciting.
So there is a clear preference for at home
red light therapy devices, which. That is
actually wrong. That statement is actually
wrong. I'm letting you know it doesn't. It
didn't.
That question was never asked in this survey.
It just said where have you used it before?
So it was weird that it would say preference.
That's actually interesting thing that you
mentioned that. Could you actually point
out exactly to that the key that you just
mentioned and help me understand where what
you mean by this is actually inaccurate?
Yes. So I can go back to design?
Yes, please.
Again, it's just.
Let me see if I can also just turn off my
video if, if that helps things on your side.
Yeah, I mean it could potentially be me.
I don't know. Okay, so you go through the
survey, it's super easy. Like the good thing
about this survey is I was like this is a
great one to test it because it's pretty
straightforward.
So we ask about red light therapy awareness.
Have you used it before? And if they say
yes, it's like, okay, what types have you
used it? Like at home in a red light therapy
bed or using a red light therapy panel. So
this doesn't.
So usage doesn't mean preference.
Right. And in the recap it said they have
a preference to at home devices, which is
not true. So the wording of preference was
to me as a researcher was like that's not
accurate. You know what I mean?
So if I just shared this with somebody, they
would be like, well no, it's just that it's
just false stuff of the wording in terms
of preference and it's if this said what
type of red light therapy do you prefer?
But have you used. So that's where you know
AI. Yeah, you have to check.
Right.
That's really right on. And if we could go
back and could you actually show me that
particular insight with a preference.
Perfect.
So here it says. And then it says it very
definite. There's a clear preference for
at home red light therapy devices, highlighting
the importance of convenience and privacy
and user adoption. So that also Nothing.
They pulled that from the Internet because
highlighting the importance of convenience
and privacy and user adoption wasn't.
Was never brought up or mentioned or anything.
So that was just pulled from AI, trying to
fill in the gaps there.
That makes a lot of sense. And Jacqueline,
while we're talking about, you know, some
of the inaccuracies that you did that you
noticed from this report, is there any other
key insight or content that came across to
you as inaccurate in addition to this?
I think that.
So I'm kind of going, I looked through it
quickly yesterday, but I can kind of go through
and call out any of the.
Yeah, I would appreciate that.
So that when it says male respondents are
less motivated by skin related benefits,
suggesting the messaging may need to be tailored
for a different demographic group, part of
that is correct. Right? Like the, the males
did rate it less.
I think it's like what's more helpful to
me is so when I look at summaries or key
findings, I don't look for actions in those.
Right. Like I like to. The way I think about
it is again, it's like here are the top three
or four things that answer the main objective
and then maybe later put suggestions. So
I, to me like suggesting something in the
summary feels that to me is not, is inaccurate.
Isn't correct. Right. Because they're it.
It make. It's like working with a junior
analyst.
They'll like, when they'll write stuff, they'll,
they'll write stuff like this, right? Like,
oh, the men don't care about the skin benefits.
So we need to talk about, you know, like
muscle recovery more. And I'm like, no, that's
not the way to think about data. So to me
this feels like junior, if that makes sense.
Okay, that's very interesting point, Jacqueline.
And okay, help me understand like what about
that, you know, key objective, let's say
key insight, follow immediate by suggestion.
Okay. What makes that a bit junior for you?
Help me understand that.
Yeah, it's, I think like when you. Because
it's not fully like through. So it's almost
like out of all the things in this survey,
right. They're bringing up as in like the
third sentence or sentence the male respondents,
which actually we didn't have a big enough
base size to really be speaking to the male
respondents that much. I think the base size
was only like, I don't Even know, like 30
or something like it.
So they're taking like this nuance about
a very small base size and trying to bucket
into the key findings and then trying to
be like, well maybe you know, like solving
something when you're like whoa, this to
me it would be the flip, right? The female
respondents were more focused on, you know,
skin related benefits where the male, the
male respondents, which was a low base size
seem to be less important to them, right?
And then like it's just a junior way of thinking
when you, when you try to get into these
weeds. And I know what they did, they basically
pulled some of these differentiators right?
Where you're like, well yeah, see there were
only, oh, it doesn't even say here how many
men.
But it isn't a lot. But they want to, they're
trying to just find like the bigger gaps,
right in data so they can call out and feels
really important. But to me that was a secondary
thing. And what I feel like would have been
really helpful here because then I poked
around and I said, oh, some of this I don't
care, like willingness to join the future
panel. Like that's not an objective.
We just put that in there every time we have
a survey, right?
Like the lower importance of skin benefits
for male. That to me is a good call out as
like a watch out of saying like you don't
have a big enough base size, you know Jaclyn,
but there is a, there, there might be something
interesting here and you're like great, right?
So but your base size isn't big enough. They,
they cut it out because of the difference
of the point I wanted to find. Like I basically
looked at this and I said, you know what
I want to see?
I want to see like, I want to see why people
were interested in red light therapy. Because
we asked some open ended questions like what
benefits really stood out to them right away.
So I like including those open ends and then
how those flowed into. We asked a question
of how important are each of these benefits
And I wanted to see it like listed out, you
know what I mean? With and then calling out
like, oh, interesting people under 30, you
know, sleep and mood was more important.
I'm making this data up, but that's what
I was looking for and I, I didn't get it.
Which is fine because I didn't expect to.
But then I wanted to be able to type stuff
in to get it, you know what I mean? I wanted
like so I wasn't playing around here like
oh, I was like, can't I help this AI summary
a little bit by asking some questions. I
even clicked on here, right?
I wanted to say list out the top benefits
from, you know, question eight for people
under 35. Like I wanted it to be more interactive
versus just it telling me that going through
and like highlighting questions that I wanted
to be included and not.
Mm, you're giving me really great discussion
points that I would touch upon. And here
what I'm hearing is that okay, so this report,
like some of it seems useful and other parts
of it seems not useful. And the useful aspect
to you seems like that key insights.
Where was it something related to key insight
number three about mail respondents. The
report is giving you a good call out like
oh hey, yeah, that's like the pattern. Maybe
it's something I have not noticed that but
unuseful aspect comes from the fact that
you only had maybe 30 or 20 very small sample
size. Exactly. Help me understand what does
like from your perspective.
Like how does small sample size relates to
unusefulness of a key insight? Can you help
me understand the relationship?
Yeah, I, you know I like to have a sample
size of at least 50.
Otherwise it's just directional feedback
and you know, reason to dig in more. But
like if I look at something and it says,
you know I hate and I do this a lot with
like studies they'll post like for politics,
you know, all of those studies are cited
and they're but so I'll open them up and
It'll be like 24 people said this and I'm
like, like that, you know what I mean? Like
to me like oh, those 24 people may have.
80% of those 24 people means nothing to me
from a data standpoint. And feeling like
I thought I saw somewhere where it did say
there was a low.
Hold on. I think it said maybe not. It did
say 88% with 10% male, 10.9%. So it did call
out. But it, I felt like it should have called
out like as a. I don't know.
And maybe the AI isn't there. Like if I was
AI, I would assume they wanted mostly female.
So I would, you know, I would position it
as like the 10% of male. Yeah, I just didn't
look at it as. And again on these key findings.
If you look here it says so it says it again.
62% use at home devices indicating a strong
preference. And again that is just, that's
not accurate. A preference is just a strong
word to use. That isn't because like I so
I.
Downloaded.
The red light team yesterday on this and
if I would have said this because they have
a red light therapy studio, I'm actually
a partner in it. And if I would say to my
partners a strong preference for home based
solutions. My, my partners would have lost
their minds. Right. Like, because it's not.
We know that, we know that's not accurate
and it is actually like kind of jarring if
you're like oh, anyway, so again, yeah. And
then like, then kind of circling back is
that I just felt like the key findings weren't
focused on the main questions. So I wanted
to select the main questions that I wanted
the feedback on. I didn't have that option
too.
Interesting.
Jacqueline, can you help understand? Can
you actually show me which were the main
questions that you. Yeah, perfect.
So, right, like this we know, like this is
good. Like all of this is good. And it's
like one. Have you heard of it? So you have
your awareness, have you used it?
So you're like kind of starting this high
level, like hold on, I'm going to try to
see if we can see my. You're kind of starting
on this like have you heard of it? Have you
used it? Where have you used it? Right.
And then we're narrowing down. And to me
these first three questions all are the same,
right. They would be like the same bullet
point and they're not the main bullet point.
Like, yeah, Red Light therapy's awareness
has gone up 30% from last year. Because I
did this survey last year.
Right. And while 50% of people used it last
year, 75% have now used it this year. I'm
making this data up, but this is about what
I would say. And then, you know, there's
an increase in people using at home devices
while still there's opportunity to grow the
beds and panels with only X amount using.
And then they look here and this is again
just to kind of level set them into what
Red Light therapy is.
And they touch on this in the key summary.
It's just weird how the order that they thought
was important. Question 7 is by far really
the only reason we did this survey. And it's
just how important are these following benefits?
How would they know?
How would AI know that? I don't know, but
it was just strange where then they only
basically touched on a few things and then
called out men. Where it's like this was
all that I wanted the insights on. And then
question eight basically supports question
seven, but AI didn't pick up on that, which
you know is fine. I feel like I'm trash talking
AI.
Hey, this is exactly why I wanted to talk
to you. Trash talk? Yeah.
Yes. Yeah. To me I wanted to tell AI though,
like hey, this is the Most important one.
Right. That's what would have been super
helpful for me because what I ended up having
to do was.
So I do want to say this. When I generated
the. This caused actually a huge headache